以下を経験するまで日本に住んだことが
あるとは言えない日本についての
コンテンツを作り始めるまで
チームラボの光の博物館の中で
迷わずにクリアができるようになるまで
吉野家の決まったオーダーができるまで
友達が日本に遊びに来た時にそのツアー
ガイド役割を
怠けるまでこれスカイツリー&
でいわゆる外人ハンターとマッチするまで
そしてその相手の目的が
英会話だけだったと気づくまで友達と寝
てるからと後でわかるまでいや
ホームシックはなったことないなと言った
直後ひどくホームシックになるまで他人
からもらったお土産を自分が買ったお土産
かのように他人に渡すまでちなみにこれは
お土産ループと言いますビールとラーメン
でお腹がいっぱいなのに別のレストランで
ビール付きのラーメンを食べるまで自分が
抱えている問題のすべてを日本のせいに
するまでそしてその間違った考えを誰かに
指摘されて逆ギレするまで
暑いねが
あっちいなぁになるまでこいつ今外人
カードを使ったなぁと裏技がバレてひどく
気まずい状況に
陥るまでスターバックスの向こう側に座っ
て自分の特別感を奪っている外国人を睨む
まで人混みの中にいながらも花見の混雑に
ついて文句を言うまでその風景をとって
Twitterにアップした人たちに
ボーナスポイントが与えられます
震度3の地震に対する
反応が
になるまで日本人の悪気のない行動に変に
切れる
経験ができるまで何で隣に座って来なかっ
たんですか外国人だからですか英語で
話しかけられたら困るからです何で英語が
できると思ったんですか外国人だからです
かはい
頭の中で
完璧にわかっているのにわびさびの説明に
失敗するまで
マーベルでもない映画のエンドロールの
最後まで見るまで
温泉の中で
隠し用のタオルを使わなくなるまで一発で
クレーンゲームに成功するまで2000円
を使ってもクレインゲームに成功しない
経験ができるまで日本人に自分の
好感度を上げるために自分の国をバカに
するまでおかしいからもうカップがこんな
に大きいよみんな銃持ってるしみんな持っ
てるの
そうだよNHKの人の気持ちがどうでも
よくなるまで
血の涙を流して勉強した感じを全て
忘れるまでこのようなことを自分が言っ
てるのは
初めてじゃないと気づくまで日本語上手
永遠に言われると悟るまで